رغم نقص الدخائر الموجهه بدقه وتعثر
انتاجها المحلي تتردد موسكو في شراء
صواريخ ايرانيه باليستيه خشيه تداعيات مثل
هذه الخطوه على الجبهه الاوكرانيه
ومكتسباتها حتى اللحظه هناك
الخشيه الروسيه من اللجوء الى ايران
تحكمها امكانيه اقدام الغربيين على تزويد
كييف بصواريخ بعيده المدى امر قد يقلب
موازين الحرب الدائره منذ اكثر من عام
ابرز مخاوف الروس ان تصل منظومه اتكمس الى
يد الاوكرانيين اذ هددت واشنطن في وقت
سابق بارسالها الى اوكرانيا منظومه
الصواريخ البالسيه اتاكمس يمكن ان يصل مدى
صواريخها الى 300 كيلومتر ما يعادل اربعه
اضعاف منظومه هاي مارس التي تلقتها كييف
من واشنطن المنظومه قادره على ضرب عمق
الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها روسيا في لوغانس
ودونتسك ما قد يضع حرب موسكو في وضع صعب
الولايات المتحده كثفت مؤخرا تحذيراتها
بشان تعميق التعاون العسكري بين روسيا
وايران حيث تعتبر العلاقه بين طهران
وموسكو مقلقه للغايه لا سيما فيما يخص
الحرب الاوكرانيه
الحلفاء الغربيون يجدون هذه العلاقه مقلقه
للغايه ومن الواضح ان هذا الوضع يزعجنا
جميعا بشكل كبير فهو يمثل موضوعا للنقاش
داخل الحلف وسنواصل ارسال اشارات الى
ايران حول مخاطر دعمها لروسيا في حربها ضد
اوكرانيا
وفقا لمسؤولين غربيين فان طهران وموسكو
بحثه امكانيه تبادل الاسلحه الروسيه
الحديثه مقابل صواريخ باليستيه لكن
المحادثات توقفت توقف محكوم بخطوات حذره
على ارض اصبح التقدم فيها ميلا يعد
انتصارا